the animatron 6000 you know what it is
and what it does not too long ago we had
it simulate a battle between the SCP
Foundation and the slimy Sinister
superhero homelander who terrorizes the
world of the boys and in the comments we
kept seeing one name pop up omniman the
terrifying almost Unstoppable viltermite
Warrior who scared the hell out of all
of us in invincible so we decided to run
a simulation to see if the SCP
Foundation could find the same success
battling this diabolical corrupted
Superman the video you're about to see
is that simulation enjoy and keep an eye
on the skies it was Unthinkable Panic
had spread throughout the foundation as
reports came in that several of the most
high-profile groups of Interest across
the globe had suffered unbearably brutal
attacks from an unknown assailant
notable among the groups targeted were
GOC Global occult Coalition as well as
its posing organization the Serpent's
hand in all incidents key buildings
belonging to the groups were demolished
and the bodies of all leadership
Personnel were discovered beaten to a
pulp these massacres appeared to send a
terrifying message whoever was behind
these attacks the foundation was most
likely next on The Chopping Block as all
containment sites prepared for the worst
it was site-17 that received subsequent
news on the matter in the most
unsettling way imaginable a small flying
object was discovered in the science
airspace and retrieved by an MTF issue
helicopter the object appeared to be an
action figure of world-renowned
superhero omniman and aboard the
trademark of Dr wondertainment toys the
mobile task force that discovered the
action figure had been on such high
alert that the appearance of this toy
almost seemed comical there was uneasy
laughter within the helicopter which
immediately turned to silence when the
toy began to speak boys and girls for
the very first time Dr wondered
attainment presents to you run
run I'll be mad it's not
the toy continued what was apparently a
pre-recorded voiceover which became
increasingly frightened and desperate as
it went along the contents of the
recording confirmed that the one
responsible for the devastation of the
other groups of Interest was none other
than omniman himself his reasons for
doing this were unknown but he seemed
adamant on wiping out all groups with
significant control over the planet's
anomalies whoever was in charge at Dr
wondertainment had uncovered the truth
shortly before omniman arrived to do the
same to their group and had deployed the
toy in a last-ditch effort to warn the
SCP Foundation it was an
uncharacteristically opaque gesture from
the terrible toy maker but the
foundation had little choice but to take
it seriously if Earth's most powerful
superhero had really gone Rogue and was
going after influential organizations in
some bid to eliminate competition the
foundation would have to develop
appropriate countermeasures as soon as
possible the first priority was was
securing the safety of the o5 council
who would most likely be the intended
victims of omniman's Rampage fortunately
their current location was extremely
classified so rather than shuffled to a
new location the council chose to stay
where they were a conspicuous relocation
process could inadvertently give the
game away especially if the aptly named
buff redacted it just launched us into
space procedure was in effect omniman
was known for his space-faring
capabilities and was fully capable of
pursuing and boarding the o5 council's
getaway shuttle if such a thing was
attempted additionally there would be no
movement of forces to the location of
the o5 council mobile task forces that
were already in the field would be
instructed to immediately cease their
current Mission and focus on locating
omniman while the superhero was
incredibly dangerous it was Paramount
that valuable time was bought so that a
better attack plan could be formulated
that was one advantage that the
foundation had over most of the other
groups of Interest the reserves to
prolong a war of attrition no matter how
strong the enemy was there was also the
matter of establishing protections for
site 17. since wondertainment had sent
the action figure there of all places to
deliver the message it was likely that
omniman would be headed there first
sight staff requested the immediate
transfer of the infamous mobile task
force tal 5 samsara a unit of immortal
cyborgs with superhuman physiology while
omniman was known to have fought and
defeated everything from the spawn of
ancient gods to cyborgs to Immortals the
four members of samsara were all three
and had strength in numbers the requests
remained pending for several minutes
causing one researcher to blithely
remark that the o5 council had probably
called dibs fearing that MTF tal 5
wouldn't arrive to intercept omniman the
researchers assessed which anomalies
contained on site would be best suited
to holding the superhero back one
ketterclass SCP in particular
immediately came to mind as CP 4051 a
male humanoid with the anomalous ability
to create extra-dimensional wormholes
these wormholes could be used to produce
any object that has scp-4051 desired
including exceedingly unstable Cognito
hazards while scp-4051's Powers were
certainly formidable it was the fact
that the humanoid who went by the name
Rainier Miller had previously been
acting as a vigilante in the United
States in other words Rainier Miller was
likely to be of special interest to
omniman even if that interest merely
amounted to having one more Target to
wipe out while it wouldn't be the only
humanoid SCP that could be considered
similar to a superhero 4051 was
definitely the closest at hand not too
long after the discussion took place the
site Radars began to pick up omniman
closing in his approach was
extraordinarily fast breaking through
the sound barrier and Landing with great
force in the center of site 17. there
was no time to waste and all available
guards and mobile Task Force personnel
were ordered to zero in on omnimance
location and opened fire as one might
expect bullets weren't exactly effective
against the superhero turned serial
killer but they did provide a plausible
distraction while the researchers
mobilized to find other means of
neutralizing omniman it was a terrifying
sight watching the costume man stand
there within a hail of bullets bearing
no outward signs of distress aside from
a Stern facial expression he moved
smoothly through the air towards the
nearest Soldier and shattered every rib
with a single punch he then grabbed
another and used him to bludgeon several
other agents even with the substantial
advantage in raw power there was a
considered tactical reason for each of
omniman's movements he systematically
made his way through the site crushing
all within his path with absolute
Prejudice there were going to be no
survivors if this continued fortunately
one of these site-17 other contingencies
was about to come into play see the
foundation had done their research and
with the corroboration of information
from other groups including the United
States government had deduced that
omniman might have psychological
weaknesses that could be exploited
namely his teenage son Mark otherwise
known by his superhero Alias Invincible
while the foundation was far too
cautious to directly contact Invincible
mostly out of fear that the boy could be
an accomplice the next best thing could
still stall omniman and give the
researchers a chance to get scp-4051
ready for combat it certainly took
omniman by surprise when he was floating
down one of the newly blood-soaked
corridors and saw Invincible standing at
the end staring him down Dad what's
going on why are you hurting them said
what appeared to be Mark Omni man
stopped in his place and his expression
changed to a look of concern for the
first time since he arrived at site 17
omnimance spoke Mark come on Ted this is
crazy you should stop this and go back
home to Mom omniman throwed his brow
something was off here for one this
version of invincible had both feet on
the ground even though he would have all
the same powers of his father also the
fact that Invincible had an approach
suggested that this individual was in
such fear of omniman that it refused to
approach omniman had been caught off
guard by this at first worried that his
son could be afraid of him to this
extent but it was starting to seem
suspicious Mark was snow coward he had
become a superhero like his father
because he wanted to protect the world
from all manner of threats although the
difference in combat experience between
the two was fast omniman knew that the
Invincible he knew was Reckless enough
to challenge him or at least have this
conversation at a regular distance his
intuition was right on the money as this
was not Invincible at all but scp-953
the polymorphic humanoid instead while
this cutter class SCP was known for
taking many forms usually that of
beautiful women the foundation staff had
given it acts access all available
information on omniman and invincible's
father-son relationship and in doing so
successfully convinced it that taking
the form of omniman's son was the best
path towards self-preservation during
this perilous scenario
scp-953 continued to make attempts at
talking to omniman doing its best to
remain still not wanting to reveal the
volpine features beneath the Invincible
costume it was wearing but omniman
proved to be too clever for this Gambit
he chuckled then suddenly zoomed forward
with his fist raised in front of him
scp-953 flinched in Terror only to find
that omniman had pulled his punch at
first scp-953 was relieved to still be
intact but this soon dissipated as the
humanoid looked at Omni man and found
none of the compassion that was on his
face just moments ago you're not Mark
omnimant said he's stronger than this
scp-953 trembled in fear the polymorphic
humanoid only had one card left to play
and it prayed that it worked 953
shapeshifted again this time into Omni
man's wife Debbie her fox-like features
were more pronounced in this form but it
was clear that the sight of his human
partner's face made omniman hesitant to
attack this hesitation was all the time
that the polymorphic humanoid needed to
run away as several guards and scp-4051
arrived to take over the duty of
stalling omniman several wormholes
opened up a round omniman deploying
Sonic grenade which stunned him for
several seconds the guards Unleashed all
of their ammo and Drew omniman's
aggression while Rainier prepared his
next weapon a wormhole to a pocket
Dimension filled with flamethrowers
which he directed at omniman hoping to
at least cause some lasting pain if not
proper burns the Flames did temporarily
obscure his vision but that didn't
hinder him for long as omniman moved
straight upwards through the ceiling
before descending back down into the
building massacring the guards
surrounding scp-4051 he looked on
Rainier with disdain especially as the
humanoid opened a wormhole and pulled
out an aluminum baseball bat you really
think a piece of Earthling sports
equipment is going to do anything to me
Omni man said it doesn't matter if it
does or doesn't when you're replied
you're not the hero you once were and
someone has to try to stop you omniman
paused reminded of his own son though
mere sentiment wouldn't be to spare
Rainier Miller the fate of the rest of
his planet and its people but Rainier
opened a wormhole directly in front of
himself which contained multiple
anti-tank rifles that fired an omni
man's Direction the impact didn't phase
omniman but it slowed the superhero down
just enough for Rainier to tuck and roll
behind him Rainier reached into another
Wormhole for a gas mask which he quickly
dawned as another one of his wormholes
Unleashed deadly poisoned gas into the
corridor omniman held his breath and
flew towards Rainier grabbing his
aluminum bat mid-swing and bending it
into an l-shape without any apparent
effort Rainier let go of his weapon but
omniman quickly grabbed him by the wrist
and lifted him into the air before
slamming him down on the ground Rainier
Miller
scp-4051 was incapacitated perhaps
fatally before omniman could confirm his
kill he was tackled and immediately
thrown to the nearest wall by the
combined force of four individuals in
cybernetic Armor mobile task force tal 5
samsara had arrived and together they
surrounded omniman and hit him with
everything they had punches and kicks
bombarded him from all angles offering
barely any window for a response the
formation didn't last long as omniman
withstood the hits and maneuvered behind
one of the members of samsara grabbing
and snapping the Cyborg's neck in one
quick motion one of its fellow members
swung from Omni man's face only for him
to catch the blow and severely batter
the arm of the attacker rendering it
unusable omniman grabbed the last two
members by the throats and squeezed
until he heard the familiar pop and
crack then he let their bodies fall of
course this wasn't enough to neutralize
samsara completely the cyber were down
but not out as their fast regeneration
began to fix their injuries with
detached contempt omniman stomped
forcefully on their heads shattering the
skulls of each member of samsara one by
one that should be a lot harder to fix
army man thought to himself he was
almost finished here then it would be on
to the next containment site and
eventually to the o5 council itself his
Planet wouldn't need meddlesome groups
like The SCP Foundation made up of
inferior humans playing at civilization
he made sure they knew how powerless
they were before the rest of the people
of viltrum arrived to complete the
conquest of Earth he applauded the
short-lived bravery of Rainier Miller
and in an uncharacteristic moment of
Mercy chose not to go back and check if
his previous opponent had truly been
killed omniman rationalized that he had
already inflicted a killing blow but
deep down as he concluded his Rampage
through site 17 and departed for the
sight of his next Slaughter he knew that
he had subconsciously gave the boy a
chance to live want to own an SCP of
your own go to scpswag.com for premium
anomalous merchandise now go check out
could homelander's ego crush the SCP
Foundation and scp-076 able vs chainsaw
man who would have the most lethal
weapon for more crossovers with the
world's wildest superheroes